here's a question for aspiring the
screenwriters is it possible to make the
movie passengers better with some
relatively minor changes you know I
don't think this is a really bad film
after hearing reviews from friends and
online I sort of expected it to be but I
think that feeling was mostly
disappointed expectation passengers is
by no means a train wreck it's just
really really predictable the plot goes
like this after the interstellar
spaceship Avalon malfunctions Chris
Pratt wakes up from hyper asleep 90
years before he's supposed to 90 years
before anyone else on the ship he can't
go back to sleep
he can't contact her if he can't get to
the ship's controls he tries to do all
of these things and fails as a year
passes he grows increasingly sad and
hopeless so eventually he decides to
wake up another passenger Jennifer
Lawrence condemning her to the same fate
essentially death in order to give
himself some more company
he acts like it's another malfunction he
doesn't tell her after a while they fall
in love she finds out the truth gets
really mad and then the ship begins to
really malfunction so Pratt sacrifices
himself to save it but in the end she
saves him they fall in love again and
spend the rest of their lives alone on
the ship happily ever after oh and
Laurence Fishburne sent it to hell oh my
god about 12 or 13 minutes in act 3 but
you know
count your blessings it's way better
than what oscar-nominated actor Andy
Garcia got so you can break this blood
up into five basic turning points one
Chris wakes up to Chris wakes Jennifer
up three she finds out for Chris
sacrifices himself and five she forgives
him the most acute tension in the film
happens between parts 2 & 3
when Jennifer starts to fall in love
with Chris but doesn't yet know the
truth we know the truth is coming is a
little dramatic irony there and so we
wait with increasing anxiety until it
does when it does predictably Jennifer
freaks out predictably and we feel a
little sadness predictably at this point
exactly an hour into the movie the
script has sort of written itself into a
corner because Pratt is the real main
character because we spend 30 minutes
alone with him at the start of the film
and see everything through his eyes
there's really only two paths to take
regarding the central relationship
either
eyes or she forgives him in both ways he
finds absolution for the sin he
committed because you're not going to be
able to turn him bad on a character like
this not unless you have five seasons to
do it and yes I know there are some
allusions to the shining here but the
shining spent pretty much no time at all
endearing us to the character of Jack
Torrance passengers spends the whole
first act endearing us to the lovable
scrappy Chris Pratt it's clear the
creators or the studio were intent on
this being a love story so they chose to
go with the schmaltz anding but they
could have chosen either the last 45
minutes would have been the same a movie
pretty much devoid of real tension or
suspense which requires a completely new
plot device in the third act the total
malfunction of the ship to juice the
ending with some adrenaline you know a
couple weeks ago I was watching Chris
Stockman and Doug Walker's joint review
of passengers and Walker said something
interesting if they told this in a
different order yeah when have been ten
times more interest yes the thing I
began to wonder is what if you
rearranged the movie so that Jennifer
Lawrence was the point-of-view character
not Chris Pratt what if the film began
with her experience well I couldn't stop
thinking about it so i readed the
existing footage see what would happen
to the story
[Music]
good morning Aurora how are you feeling
you just spent 120 years in suspended
animation
[Music]
grounding concourse anybody hello hi hey
passenger our crew
passenger Jim Preston do you know what's
going on nobody else from my RoboCup
same for me when I made this change and
just watched from there some interesting
things started to happen first of all
the first act changes its tone entirely
with the original first act you're
wandering around the ship with Chris
Pratt you learn cool things you see him
come to terms of the situation have fun
get depressed and finally reach the
ethical dilemma that's meant to animate
the movie what you see is what you get
here which makes for somewhat passive
viewing experience it's an amusing
sequence but that's mostly down to cool
production design and Pratt's always
charming performances yes I am going to
die of old age on the ship but in the
new first act the story is infused from
the start with mystery when I made the
editing changes I was genuinely
surprised by just how creepy Pratt's
character is when you take away his
point of view we don't know whether to
trust him or not believe him or not and
that makes the audience's experience an
active one in every moment you know it's
Cayenne but nobody else in my role okay
same for me as he leads Jennifer around
the ship locations become crime scenes
where the viewer tries to figure out
what's happening this of course by the
way is what makes andrei tarkovsky so
Laura's so great so much has happened on
Solaris by the time the lead character
arrives that he and the audience have to
piece the fragments together themselves
I mean just look at how creepy he is I
actually think that Pratt's performance
takes on more dimensions from this angle
you're not always forced to see him as
sympathetic so his darker side comes out
in greater relief more important than
that the dark choice that sits at the
heart of this film hits with greater
impact when seen from the first time
from Lawrence's perspective because we
feel the cruelty as she feels it did he
lately
I try not so now we're at the point
where the original story hits that dead
end
but with this new edit you have some
more options to play with namely with
this configuration you could actually
turn Pratt into the villain the original
film suggests that can't follow through
on and make passengers into the thriller
horror film that so many critics wanted
to see you can even cut back in that
whole first section of Chris's time
alone on the ship but put it after the
revelation without the need to justify
his good guidance you could show a
deeper more desperate side to his
loneliness something that I think
actually would make him more sympathetic
in the end and the choice he makes more
agonizing
[Music]
of course this simple cut and paste
doesn't solve every problem in the
script the ending for example is still
an issue I think you'd want to remove
the malfunction MacGuffin but it might
be just as trite to closed the story in
true horror fashion it could be equal to
give it a Twilight Zone ending as Peters
credits last film suggested and have
Pratt die and Laurence gets so lonely
that she begins to contemplate the same
horrible choice brainstorming like this
is obviously really fun and much easier
than actually writing a movie and making
one for all its faults passengers is a
big-budget movie with a completely
original script and that should be
celebrated because it's a dying breed
but it's done like this is a good
opportunity for would-be screenwriters
to think about story because you can
learn just as much from films that don't
work as you can from those that did hey
everybody thank you so much for watching
this episode was brought to you by
Dollar Shave Club you might have noticed
that I have appeared everybody with a
beard will tell you that if you don't
keep things clean it can get really
scruffy really quickly so I use Dollar
Shave Club razors to make sure all the
lines on my neck and cheeks are smooth
and even and it's the smarter choice
because they send everything you need
right to your door at an affordable
price you have to go to the store you
don't have to spend money on unnecessary
technology and for a limited time you
can get the executive razor with a tube
of dr. Carver's shade butter for just
five dollars no shipping fee and razors
are only a few bucks a month after that
here's what you get in the box get a
nice sturdy handle get your four razors
and of course dr. Carver's shea butter
don't leave home without it make sure
you really easy no commitments no
hassles and if you go to
dollarshaveclub.com slash nerdwriter you
can get that first month for $5 the
links at the top of the description
that's dollarshaveclub.com slash
nerdwriter thanks guys I'll see you next
week